hey guys welcome back to Brand Nev
you're back I'm monster on a roll again
instead are gonna be talking about how
to get the new weapon in Monster herb or
with the summer festival called the
shooting star lane so it was always like
the view if you do enjoy a subscriber
free new I cover the solo guides of
monster on a world the event quests
every week to keep everyone up today I
want to do and tips and tricks to make
everyone a better Monster Hunter player
and with that let's get started with the
video so which one to be doing is the
quest midnight mayhem which will
basically allow you to kill 10 gas
students in the arena and then you will
be getting first fleet tickets which
will allow a ticket the shooting star
lands and its upgrades the shooting star
lancer rarity it the shooting star Lance
is a rarity for Lance with 299 raw
damage 120 paralysis damage and 0
affinity with the upgraded version being
the Sapphire star Lance at rarity 7 437
raw damage 180 paralysis 2 augments and
0 affinity just like before now I
personally am NOT a Lance expert I'm
more of a dual blades guy so any Lance
users tell me if this weapon is better
than any current Lance's in the game
specifically paralysis as well I love to
know your thoughts on this and yeah just
a very simple video and to tell you how
to get the new shooting star lands and
of course the upgraded version sapphire
star Lance so what that like to be if
you do enjoy so discover for new I
covered the solo guides and Monster
Hunter World the event quests any
festival stuff every week just to let
everybody know what the quests are and
what to do and tips and tricks to make
everyone a better Monster Hunter player
and with that guys my two most recent
videos would be on the screen now if you
guys want to check that out that guy's a
very great astir day thank for watching
the video
peace out